what would be the statistical approach
before you get married
what are we talking about how many
people should one possibly
have sex with well there are strategies
algorithms that you can look at to pick
something out of a bunch yeah yes and so
um
i looked at what i like to call the 12
bonk rule the 12 bonk rule yes you're
starting to talk my life
the first mathematical term you've views
that i understand
the 12 bonk rule
12
sexual encounters well people always say
do you have to bonk them and i say well
no but you may as well because that's
not a scientific term
bonk is not a scientific term and we
only talk science here i say do the deed
do you have so you're saying no you
don't actually have to but you have to
sort of be around each other and
mess around a little bit this is the
whole thing in a world where there are
so many people how can we test so you
can do the math it takes about 20
minutes for me to explain properly and
do the equations right no i submitted
romney though um you take 12 like if you
test 12 this is take the next best
algorithm you test 12 you reject the
first 12. brad pitt you go sorry mate
got to continue wait a minute you're
saying if a woman is using your method
okay and she wants to she needs to first
have 12 bonks with 12 men and brad pitt
shows up second or third she has to
still reject him she needs to analyze
him see where he fits in the pack and
then say out you go because you're in
the first 12 and that means
mathematically that's not a good t
that's not a good example this says so
the take the next best so all women
watching right now are like no
no
if brad pitt shows up first and you've
never been with a guy before you're
sticking with brad pitt well it's a 75
chance of success not a hundred percent
but when divorce is 50
got to weigh up your odds you've got to
be you've got to put that logical hat on
right forget your star sign right so you
bonk 12 right reject them all right then
you pick the next best for you so that's
not 13 the next best for you could be 50
right the next best so you pick the best
one in the first 12. this is such a
great scientific mathematical excuse for
having a ton of sex
right and also break getting out of
relationships it can't help you it's
math
can't do anything about it
right
can i just say yeah
so
if you've had way more than 12 remember
math is a study of patterns so it's not
saying what's right or wrong if you've
had way more than 12 like i suspect you
guys are in the entertainment industry
i've had more than 12 i'll happily admit
that you um have one
sure sure more than 12. yes
wait do you mean you mean people or time
yeah
that's a good one
[Music]
this does alone time count
because then i'd marry myself
you're the best i'm the best you're the
best i'm the best i've had
if you've had way more than 12 it's not
saying there's something wrong with you
yeah just saying well i know i've had
more than 12 and i i know that i've
probably met someone that i could be
very happy with but i obviously need a
bit of therapy maybe i'm a bit of a
workaholic yeah yeah you know obsessive
compulsive no what's really stalking
mathematician not at all not at all you
let's get into the actual math you say
mathematically
let's get into it
this is my sexual come on to women at
bars
let's get into the math of it my dear
another round for everyone um